I think one of the most challenging aspects of life
is this concept of "self."
Who am I?
Am I what I do?
Who I hang out with?
Where I spend my time?
When I was younger, I was looking
for myself in all the wrong places.
So..I'm in this bag of mushrooms.
I did a lot of experimental things
in my "journey" for self discovery..
Where are the pockets?
Where am I supposed to..
That's not safe.
Ultimately, I realized that there's
no shortcuts.
If you want to find out who you are,
then you have to spend time with yourself.
So, I went on a 5-day silent
meditation retreat in Joshua tree,
and it was hard! Oh, it was so
hard! It was like,
you couldn't talk, and it was
from 5:00AM to 9:00PM
just, straight-up meditation..
half-hour increments of sitting meditation
and walking meditation.
Ugh, so hard..
And I wasn't a saint.
I went crazy around day 2
and I went on this online shopping spree
on my phone.
"Tell me I'm real."
And I ended up calling a friend because
I couldn't bear just being in the
silence of my own thoughts.
On the last day, we had to gather around
in a semi circle
and we each had to say in one word
our experience of the..the entire ordeal.
And so people were saying things like,
"Love." "Friendship." "Trust."
And when it came to me, I said,
"Supercalifragilisticexpialidocious."
And everyone just broke into laughter.
And I was like, "This is me."
Right there, in that moment,
that was me.
And more importantly..
I like me.
Aaand I'll see you next Monday.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Ew, your balls are weird!
They look like they're scabby from neutering..
You're all scabbyballs!
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara